voyez comme il a et à l'humidité ça vous
le même cerveau après quelques rôles de
nous c'est trop love et à l'humidité qui
coule draguer dans la chambre parce que
le cancer ne faut pas rester à dos
l'imax
hayatou ya une souris à l'humidité les
frustrations de l'eau au niveau du
plafond dao et
[Musique]
extraits cités sinon ici ça s'effondre à
la fin de cette fois d'aller trop et on
regarde cette situation c'est vous qui
disent ah ouais c'est noir ceux ci
portent là sinon en fait les branches
notre vidéo
on a la ramener pour l'occasion tout
seul faisait qu'attirer 6 et sont faites
de petits potins de castres a fixé pas
il obtient une fuite de gaz une
catastrophique oriente donc si je peux
pas voir là on peut pas par exemple la
ferme en laissant de gaza parce qu'on a
pas d'écrit cité mais rien n'est rien si
c'est par exemple est un fait si
catastrophique demandé dans les
toilettes maintenant s'il était un brin
déjà si on met les gironde y sont
conviées métrage rapport pour faire nos
besoins des gens
après la douche j'ai envie de faire un
de jeu par exemple une fusion mais j'ai
pas du moins de faire chez les jeunes
matt duchene gens alors on voit de
chimie sa pensée entier rien
[Musique]
apple a chez le concessionnaire je suis
d'origine roumaine j'habite ici depuis
février 2017 avec mon mari depuis
février depuis février 2017
jusqu'à mach 2002 j'en appelle 600h
armand jallet qui tenteraient la salle
de bain ainsi manger de méditer je crois
qu'elle a le mérite elle va tomber quoi
je parle je travaille je laisse tout
propulsant le 60 ben quoi je rentre tout
ça sachant l'humidité donc ce sont ces
grands journaux ça me tombe le ciel
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de gens que j'ai la demande
de logement social aux correspondants
curien la caf il met pas ça fait deux
ans que je vais aller avec eux
l'assistance aussi allée lundi qu'il va
parler avec la caf et rien du tout donc
je touche pas d'hésitation je suis pas
assistées sociales géante où je bosse
comme tout le monde j'ai un salaire de
la chaque fois moi je me lève à 7h du
matin à six heures pour arriver le
premier à la casse parce que moi après à
9h 10h ce travail et les maladies
balade une balade à nos attentes elle
juste at on des félins plan-là vas-y
l'âge et la base est là je vois pas tous
les aléas qui bouge et à led rouge
j'ai été j'ai un dossier plein il est
comme sa plainte au pied et en
assistance sociale qui appelle parfois
m'a juste pour prendre des nouvelles si
nos 115 915 9 pas à 115 et surtout le
matin elle dit souvent que ça le soit
sur mon site à deux places s'il ne donne
pas moi je peux parler d' à 115 avec ma
fille parce qu'ils jouent les smashes de
respect de la part prise et je suis en
colère parce que ça bouge bien le moins
de l'année alors tout doux
[Musique]
j'entends y parle de clea le nouveau
volet va devenir nouveau peut comparer
quoi c'est vrai je suis content
quettehou mais j'aimerais bien profite
mais aussi pourquoi me mouson est mise
en faillite repoussé c'est pas comme les
autres j'aimerais bien
tant que mon mari travaille et on est
comme la légende normal le travail
cherche ainsi toit pour lui pour moi
pour mes enfants
o comme si on est oblique mois nous on
s'incline sachant manier ici ont grandi
ici
alors tout à fait normal que peut-être
ils peuvent proposer un truc on aimerait
bien parti le repas concert bien les
gens mais malheureusement oui à chaque
fois on me dit non
aussi la rentrée chambre qui chante
petite maison à kuan yew cohérente
agricole mais rend discrètement les uns
par que leurs copains qui vont être en
crise pouvait mais en vie dans la misère
quoi
[Musique]